saint roch de l'achigan dans lanaudière
est l'exemple parfait de ce que provoque
l'étalement urbain la ville à 40 km du
centre ville de montréal est aux portes
de la communauté métropolitaine
habiter ici coûte moins cher et saint
roch est devenu un lieu de vie recherché
par les jeunes familles et les
promoteurs moi je soulève le 10 ans on
court après le développement fassent un
roc bonjour tout celle inverse ces
développements qu'il pourra près on à
5500 habitants qui voudraient abandonner
le développement savoir ça commence très
fort ça finit par cbc mars il fait
partie d'une nouvelle génération
fraîchement élu de jeunes mères
québécois très sensible à
l'environnement on l'a rencontrée devant
un développement de maisons
unifamiliales qui avait été autorisée
avant qu'il soit maire ce sera un des
derniers dans sa municipalité
à l'ère du bungalow là c'est terminé
d'abord à terme de rentabilité pour les
municipalités les résultats sont pas
nécessairement à laurent fut vraiment
plus densifiées zaqout minimalement deux
fois plus cher faire du développement en
mode étalement urbain que du
développement en mode consolidation
identification on est obligé de
construire des autoroutes une nouvelle
école ont de plus de tuyaux d'aqueduc
d'égout à saint roch de l'achigan les
immeubles multi logements ont donc
commencé à pousser sur les terrains
encore vacants du territoire de la ville
l'étalement urbain
je ne donne pas grand chose ça diminue
prétexte azouni ya des poches en plus
hautement il me fait qu on veut que ça
reste comme ça on peut en faire encore
un autre développement un peu plus loin
en arrière avec des quadruples aixois ya
vraiment pas de problème je sais qu'il
faut pas que ça que ça monte ça devienne
un repenti une comprenait la démographie
de la couronne de montréal explose
lanaudière les laurentides et la
montérégie compte et en 2020 140 mille
résidents de plus qu'en 2016 qu'on
arrête de gaspiller nos territoires de
je dirais même de la scrap et de
produire des quartiers de très faible
qualité
dépend dans l'automobile où les gens
aucun service à proximité
alexandre turgeon a siégé au comité
consultatif pour la future politique
d'aménagement du territoire québécois
c'est ce qu'ils deviennent marché
acheter a une qui existe qui sait la
maison crépeau démolissait la paire
construisez la halle la clé dit il est
d'exploiter les friches urbaines
existantes et de l'est densifier de
façon intelligente comme ici dans le
secteur pointe aux lièvres à québec
on y retrouve depuis cinq ans ce projet
vanté par bien des urbanistes 52 unités
de deux étages habitée surtout par de
jeunes familles la cour intérieure leur
apporte de l'intimité et le c'était bien
localisé à deux pas de la rivière saint
charles
on aime beaucoup justement la cour les
enfants peuvent jouer de manière
autonome sécurité le jeu au pied les
appartements sont bien aménagés aussi
l'espace à la seconde on a découvert le
projet on a obligé on a obligé tout de
suite l'idée d'un bungalow à en banlieue
ce qu'on est vraiment chercher ces sera
prochainement non bio travail est limité
des transports quotidiens parmi les bons
exemples à montréal il y a le projet
plateau police situé sur le terrain d'un
ancien concessionnaire automobile dans
l'est du plateau mont royal on ya
construit 196 unités réparties dans cinq
bâtiments lien supermarché au
rez-de-chaussée des logements sociaux et
là aussi une cour intérieure dans la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
85% des unités qui sont construites sont
à multilogements il ne reste que 15 pour
sa d'unifamiliales
est ce qui démontre bien que le marché
aussi est à la densification et la
consolidation christian savoir souligne
qu'aucune demande de dézonage pour du
résidentiel n'a été accepté dans la cmm
depuis l'adoption du plan métropolitain
d'aménagement en 2011 ça démontre que la
planification
lorsqu'elle se donne d'aida fonctionne
la densification n'est pas seulement un
enjeu pour les villes le village de
saint-elzéar en beauce où vivent deux
mille six cents personnes doit aussi
gérer l'arrivée de nouveaux résidents et
même ici les jumelés où les immeubles
multi logements ont commencé à
apparaître en aidant les terres
agricoles donc nos entreprises agricoles
sont très importants pour nous donc
toujours mettre une pression sur eux
c'est une solution la solution à
saint-elzéar est passé par un nouveau
schéma d'aménagement tous les nouveaux
terrains développement le promoteur la
str6 notaire en était réduit donc deux
environ 25% l'autre chose aussi c'est
qu'on a mis une taxation supplémentaire
pour les terrains vacants dont on
construit qui sont déjà desservies par
l'aqueduc et les égouts les mesures
commencent à rapporter mais ces mères
qui font leur part espère maintenant que
québec aura l'audace de revoir la
fiscalité municipale
il ya quelque chose de débiles latin
mais de même atteindre municipalité mois
comme mr le juge décide de porter un
boisé économique mal 0 rentabilité jour
même aux contrastes une perte économique
temps où son tacle de scrap et des
terres agricoles démunis naturel vont
rapporter plus que de les protéger leurs
données en un problème les règles
actuelles sont dignes des années 70
conclut sébastien mars il lui comme les
jours bat nice rencontre et espère
maintenant un tournant pour
l'environnement les finances et le
développement
l'histoire québécois